Google Cloud updates for Google Cloud
deploy the price of an active delivery
pipeline is now reduced also single
Target delivery pipelines no longer
incur a charge and you can see the
pricing page for more details and
speaking of spending we've got a great
blog post on how to build a phenops
roadmap it'll go through everything to
help you avoid overwhelm and take
advantage of all the super cool features
all without having that bill sneak right
up on you and it's full of helpful tips
and tricks from Finn Ops workshops that
we've completed with our customers check
out the links below for everything we
covered on this week's